hello everyone my name is reto meier and
welcome to this week in Android
development October 22nd 2012 if you've
ever wondered what happens when you
combine a love of Android with an
appreciation for fine grilled meats you
are probably one of the hundreds of
Android meat lovers to descend on Hurst
Texas for the big Android BBQ last
weekend meanwhile in Germany DFS Berlin
was in full swing last week with one
highlight being the impromptu you
Android design in action session held at
sea bass hosted by Nick butcher and
special guest designer Marie schweetz
while Nick was enjoying the worst and
beer of Germany rich Hyndman was in
Italy enjoying pasta pizza and
presenting at the Ferengi death fest you
can meet both Nick and rich this week at
droidcon London the annual celebration
of all things Android in the beating
heart of old London town was also a big
week for the Google Play team with the
launch of self-support in India which is
now the fourth largest market for app
downloads worldwide they also launched
the new sleeker faster and easier to
navigate Android developer console
details for which can be found on the
Android developer blog to celebrate the
big week you can join the developer
console team for a special hang out on
monday 12 p.m. london time should you be
in possession of a functional time
machine had the app clinic been in
possession of such a device we could
have avoided the string of failures that
have plagued our broadcasts in recent
weeks as the Google founders have
instead chosen to invest their
discretionary budget in self-driving
cars and wearable computers we had to
rely on alternative techniques for
success we did so in style last week
successfully broadcasting not one but
two app clinics starting with the
long-awaited video player app clinic
only one day later than promised on
Wednesday morning having wisely chosen
not to rely on our success Nick Roman
and Adams Android design in action
completed to design for a hypothetical
video player then on Friday in and I
will back at it reviewing shopping list
apps tune in this Tuesday as the design
in an action team present their take on
out of milk and grocery IQ it turns out
that there may still be a rich market
for developers of pumpkin carving and
candy cataloging apps so this week we'll
be announcing some exciting changes to
future our clinic broadcasts rather than
trying to review non-existent Halloween
apps in the meantime use this Trello
board to nominate the apps and app
categories you'd like us to review in
future weeks
another Android developer live
broadcasts this week dan will be back
again for the Friday games review and
our regular office hours will be
broadcast from London Mountain View and
Brazil where Bruno will once again be
dispensing what I can only hope is
Android development knowledge in
Portuguese if this week in Android
doesn't offer you a rich enough variety
of Australian accents tune in to Ankur
Kotwal weekly ad l+ last week he covered
notifications and this week you'll have
more details on the ADL plus experiments
with connectivity AP is a new Android
documentation this week the
notifications API guide has received an
update to include rich notifications as
always we look forward to you joining us
for our many live shows the schedule of
which you can find a Google developers
live today's live wallpaper was galactic
core from kitty face software and
remember missing you is dark grey all
alone my name is reto Meier thanks for
watching